almost every Android app has to open
third-party content at some point at
that moment developers need to decide if
they open that content in the browser or
use a web - opening links in the browser
is a heavyweight transition from the
application and doesn't allow you to
customize the UI this may frustrate
users and make it harder for them to
return to your app using a webview gives
you more control of the UI but it's
harder to build it doesn't include all
the cool features that browser
developers work hard to provide wouldn't
it be nice if you could have the best of
both worlds that's why we created custom
tabs
my name is Andrew Banda and with chrome
custom tabs 30 buy content in your app
is a first-class citizen
chrome custom tabs is a new way to show
third-party content on Android that
allows you to change how chrome look and
feels making the transition from web to
web seamless by using custom tabs you
can customize chrome to match your
application color change the start and
exit animations or add a custom action
to the toolbar like a burden to save an
article to read later it also features a
customizable up button that makes it
easier for the user to return to your
app on stone with the content being a
part of Chrome it shares the same cookie
jar so your users won't have to log in
frequently to view third-party content
it also makes it easier for the content
publishers to track user engagement
coming from your application you also
get the chrome features like for moto
fill geolocation prompts and page
translation but it is also about speed
as it allows your app to ask chrome to
preload content in the background so
that when users click on a link it will
open really fast reloading content can
make the links inside your app open up
to three times faster than using a
normal chrome tab or a webview chrome
custom tabs is already available
starting for Chrome version 45
okay let's take a look at how to use
chrome custom tabs in your android app
first add the android support library to
your project build file to enable warm
up and pre loading you need to connect
to the browser service once connected
you can ask chrome to warm up to
prefetch the content create a new
navigation session optionally passing a
callback now you are ready to West
chrome to prefetch the third party
content you can give it a single URL or
if you need more you can add a list of
other URLs the user is likely to
navigate chrome will prioritize the
first URL followed by the all other URLs
on the list in the order pass it to it
and don't forget to unbind the service
when chrome custom tabs is no longer
needed
now if possible chrome will start to
prefetch the content it may go all the
way from resolving DNS to fetching the
page and support contents like CSS
JavaScript and images and even preventer
the page up to the point that all that
remains is to actually draw the pixels
on the screen you hope a chrome tab by
using a custom tab intent pass it a
reference to the host activity and the
URI want to open if the URI matches the
one one of the URIs pass at me
prefetching chrome will use the prefetch
'add content otherwise it will fetch and
render the page at that moment there are
various customizations possible in the
custom tab you I use them by calling the
corresponding methods on the custom tabs
intent pewter to change the application
bar color for instance you need to call
the set to bar color methods chrome
custom tabs is a powerful tool that
allows your application to open web
content in a seamless way by using it
you get the white flexibility of a
webview
increases the user retention and create
a seamless transition between your app
and in the web you also get a shared
cookie jar from out of view and all the
other cool
features from chrome improving even more
the user experience in providing better
metrics for content publishers it also
has the unique advantage of being able
to prefetch the content making it load
faster all those features make it the
best solution when opening third-party
content in your application it's also an
open specification which means that
other browsers beside chrome may support
it if you want to see how to integrate
chrome custom tabs in your Android app
check out them on github or if you have
questions you can send them on the Stack
Overflow tag chrome custom tabs next
time you want third-party content in
your app let chrome pick up the tab